d'en réunion périssable bougie lampe
produit pharmaceutique après 10 jours de
collecte la réserve communale de Poissy
à le sourire devant la mairie la ville a
réussi à collecter près de 500 kg au
profit du peuple ukrainien une opération
réalisée à l'occasion des 1 an du
conflit en Ukraine ça c'est formidable
vous savez la France a connu des heures
sombres voilà dans ces guerres mondiales
notamment la notamment la deuxième on
sait ce que c'est que d'être martyrisé
et on sait aussi ce que c'est qu'être
libéré et de se tenir droit et la France
se tient droit aux côtés aujourd'hui des
Ukrainiens l'intégralité des dons est
remis à l'association caritative
abeilles d'Ukraine une organisation
créée après le début de la guerre à part
des Ukrainiens qui comptent aujourd'hui
des dizaines de membres la structure
humanitaire envoie régulièrement des
cartons collectés dans la région sa
présidente Oxanna est toujours émue par
cette générosité on est sans qui est
c'est fatiguant des fois pour les gens
nous on comprend mais nous des
Ukrainiens ont pas le choix on peut pas
tomber
on est toujours continué on fatigue
jamais je crois qu'il faut qu'on
continue aide une grande partie de la
collecte se renvoyer le 5 mars dans
l'est de l'Ukraine la ville de Poissy
n'exclut pas d'organiser d'autres
opérations pour le peuple ukrainien dans
les prochains mois
[Musique]